the number of children who have died
from strep a across the UK since
September has now risen to 19. our
science correspondent Thomas Moore has
the details
this is an update on the numbers from
the health Security Agency and they say
that there have been 16 in a deaths
under the age of 18 in England another
three uh in Wales and Northern Ireland
and they've also said that so far in
this season and the season starts in in
mid-september there have been 74 deaths
in England so they're not orphaned off
of adults who are dying from strep a too
and they've also given us some numbers
on the previous bad year for
streptococcus a there's bacteria that
really is moving around the country very
quickly back in
2017-18 which was the last bad year
there were 355 deaths across the whole
season and 27 of those were under the
age of 18. and and also they've been
encouraging people to to come forward if
people do have what they call strep
throat or scarlet fever
um they're making the point that these
are very easily treated with antibiotics
now just to remind you on the symptoms
of a strep throat that is a fever sore
throat swollen glands and a headache
scarlet fever generally a childhood
illness which has a characteristic
sandpapery rash and a swollen tongue
encouraging people to contact their GP
or nhs11 at an early stage so that those
children can be assessed there's also
been a change to the regulations over
prescriptions today something called a
serious shortage protocol that allows
pharmacists to prescribe an alternative
antibiotic if the antibiotic that's
written on the prescription by the GP
has run out and and that should make it
much easier for parents to to get a hold
of antibiotics really quickly